[Music]
the seven kingdoms is a single realm
made up of seven realms that once were
independent and the north is uh perhaps
the largest
even in the height of summer they get
snows up there because they are so far
north
winterfell is the major castle the seat
of house stark
it's not a city or town so much as it is
a
castle a stronghold a fortress you're a
stark of winterfell
you know our words winter is coming you
were born in a long summer
you've never known anything else but now
winter is truly coming
winter is coming stark words and because
summer's
so long in this land where we are the
winters are equally long
the words of historic winter is coming
are of course very literal in
westeros winter is coming but i think it
has meaning beyond that
winter is coming for all of us and in
our own lives there's always times of
times of darkness and death so every
house in westeros has its heraldry and
the stark heraldry is a dire wolf
direwolves existed in the real world
they were actual
prehistoric wolves ned stark is a
childhood friend of the current king
robert baratheon
you've got fat
vet stark is a man of honor he's the
moral heart of the story he's a man
who's always trying to do the right
thing
he's fundamentally a good man he's a man
who loves his wife
and he loves his children he has a large
family
he's married to caitlyn pulley stark
lady stark
she's a very dear wife someone who's
very
grounded theirs is a very genuine true
marriage
they're completely devoted to each other
and together they have a number of
children the eldest son rob to be a man
and to be a stark is a very difficult
thing
we're all bound by a sense of duty and
responsibility
sophie plays sansa who is the girl from
the provinces who desperately wants to
be a part of the action
in the big city she's the sort of girl
that believes in princes and when her
prince is going to come and
take her on the horse and ride away into
the moonlight arya is mischievous and
she wants to be a boy and she's active
and she doesn't like sewing
she has scruffy clothes scruffy hair
you know she goes on the run and then
there's lovely brown at the end
he lives quite an easy life to start
with he loves climbing he's the son of a
lord
and the youngest rickon who's just a
boy of six also living in his household
jon snow
who is a bastard and you are a stark you
might not have my name
he had my blood the strain comes when it
comes to john's
secret history he doesn't know where
he's come from what his father did what
he did
is my mother alive every time we see
each other
i'll talk about your mother ned's father
and his own elder brother were
killed by the preceding thing ned's
younger brother benjen
is a ranger of the night's watch the
night's watch
protects the realm against a band of
people called the wildlings who live
beyond the wall
i'm the first ranger job is out there
winter is coming winterfell is one of
the first places they get hit
by everything that comes and everything
that comes with it the weather
supernatural
elements after the wall it says the
garden or the starks
the starks of winterfell traced their
descent to the first men
in the age of heroes the family's
founder was brandon the builder who
in the aftermath of the long night
helped establish the night's watch
legend has it he enlisted the aid of
giants and the powerful magic of the
children of the forest
to raise the mighty wall which has
protected the realm for generations
he went on to build the ancestral seat
of winterfell and reigned as the first
king in the north
the starks reigned as kings for
thousands of years
even withstanding the invasion of the
andals
as the southern kingdoms fell and the
children of the forest were driven away
the north stood strong maintaining its
religious customs and its way of life
eventually the reign of the kings of
winter came to an end with the coming of
aegon the conqueror
after aegon and his dragons destroyed
the combined armies of the reach and the
rock
at the field of fire king tauren stark
bent the knee and swore fealty to the
targaryen dynasty
in order to spare the destruction of
winterfell and his people
he was forever after known as the king
who knelt
as a reward for his submission aegon
named tauren
lord of winterfell and warden of the
north
the starks take great pride in their
history and traditions
it is one of the few noble houses that
still keeps the old gods
a sacred weirwood tree looms large in
winterfell's godswood
its ancestral sword ice was forged in
ancient valeria
and has been passed down through the
generations
house stark remains steadfast in its
support of the night's watch
even as the once illustrious order has
fallen on hard times
much like their sigil the grey direwolf
how stark is the stuff of legend in the
north and throughout the seven kingdoms
and their family words winter is coming
serve as a reminder of their beginnings
in the wake of the long night
and agree importance of things to come